hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription there's
something to do with this where am i
okay
there's something to do with that data
connector but then again i did see
something over yes
so that was probably all that it was it
probably isn't anything more than that
so many files to inspect
also i did see this i
believe my face 100 subscribers that's
right those are scrub numbers babies get
those numbers up what's going on over
here who's over here who's there network
damn it
maybe i gotta wait for it maybe it's a
patience test
i'm not patient enough
also what the hell is wrong with you
i could have sworn that i would have
gotten it it's not really something to
swear it's not like there are other
symbols here but this is clearly a skull
and crossbones so
you know that seems like it's something
that needs to be done
i will go through all of them i will
i'll do it should i
should i not shouldn't i
i really want to solve it
[Music]
all right
okay i have officially determined that
you cannot brute force this
or there's some indication that i wasn't
seeing when it was actually done and i
didn't really know so that was a big
waste of time i don't know why there's a
skull there but whatever it's fine all
right hey look i know i've been away for
a while but let's just get back into the
game okay
i'm here to play
yes this area is good what's the feeling
pride feels weird
why why does that feel weird
why would any of that feel weird can i
recycle something yay
oh trade i don't want it whoa what is
that
if a card bearing the sigil is within a
circuit when it perishes a random card
is created in your hand okay so it only
works if it's in a circuit but i don't
know how any of the circuit does
anything empty space is within a circuit
completed by a card bearing the sigil
spawn jam vessels at the end of the
owner's turn
i don't want any of these uh
i guess a kind cell will you give i
don't know man i don't know
oh
i guess a sentry drone
i guess
i don't really know what else to do
okay oh recycling hi oy mate
look at me now something of a celebrity
around here
me rewards for dredging up that thing
i get to be something of a dialogue npc
okay whatever i'm not good at that i'm
not going to pretend like i am
pick your worst one i'm trying man i'm
trying which one do i hate okay so kind
cell and giftbot i could get back
exactly what you just gave me kind cell
[ __ ] off i don't want to deal with
circuits i know i'm going to have to i
know it's going to make me
but i don't want to deal with circuits
i just don't
thank you for the money
all right goodbye
now farewell
oh
okay so this was kind of circuitous
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa what was that oh
i thought i saw something
can i go up the ladder whoa
neat
damn
i'm pretty good
what is this
what another upgrade for you
this one is free
your empty vessels are going to be
conduits now don't worry about it
well i didn't think i was going to worry
about it but now i'm kind of worried
about it
done
you just had to be patient
i mean i was but whatever
all right i don't know how that works so
i'm going to find out with a battle
hi everybody
let me play i will man i will don't
worry about it i got a robot that's nice
no conduit buff conduit okay conduit
tower
well that's interesting
oh you're only one oh that's nice can
you kill this uh
buff conduit when it comes out that's
probably the more important thing
i'm feeling stimulated
bang
[Music]
hey stop that
wait
why would i want to make a conduit up
there i don't why is it talking about
that oh no that's just the power zone
okay that's fine
shield bot
um i could start chipping away at this
thing
wham
thank you
i forgot that those got turned into
turrets now so
that's very nice that's very nice okay
um
see what else we can get
gift bot yeah i'll play you
what are you gonna give me
oh yeah
both hound not very useful
uh
do i win
almost
[Music]
hey pal moon gears in here let's get
down to business
i guess i should try to kill that thing
i'm not exactly oh aurora bot that's
easy how i'm gonna kill that thing
that much is very clear
nothing's gonna die in no time
well then in the meantime
i'll just
keep drawing i guess
and you kill
it's coming up over there
finish it off
take that
hey
ow all right well you really uh
earned it this time pal
get ready can i please get to the place
where i can pick up the hammer oh
right card of course
hi y'all
uh goodbye
my injuries are severe i shall retire
for now
uh
[Music]
goodbye we
such a lovely day to win at a card game
all right so what was that all about
what is this you probably think what i
do is easy fiddle with the numbers tweak
the graphics and voila botopia is made
no you're wrong you try making a card go
ahead but first pick one to recycle
so which one am i scrapping i don't know
i guess one of the exoskeletons since i
got two
[Music]
but why one scrap power i see i see i
see i see okay
what does a double gunner get me
one sp
what would this do i'm not gonna do it
two that's it two sp
[Music]
five ah
it's how many things they have on them
that's what really matters and nothing
has more things than lonely wizbot and
or fishbot
i mean it would be really stimulating
for a lonely wizbot it would be really
stimulating
but am i that cruel what about fishbot
fishbots not particularly useful and i
don't really have an attachment to him
i'm kind of partial to lonely wizbot so
i think it's gotta be fishbot
it's a tragedy
choose me well he's saying he
volunteered you heard him it's happening
goodbye
all right genius go for it okay
spend sp on stats and sigils you get
more sp for a higher energy cost
okay
oh i see i have sp right now because it
cranked out 5sp
wow
[Music]
this one gives you an sp
think yeah
weird
oh i get to pick it oh cool
oh hell yeah frankenhead
oh wow
i love him
oh
wow
these are great i gotta go with shotgun
shotgun frankenstein i love him
or regretful
regretful
gentleman
the regretful gentleman
all right hang on let's crank up this sp
cost um let's put him at a four i don't
have much that costs four
now let's put him at three compared to
where the other ones were
let's give him some nice attack some
health to survive a hit
uh
we don't need unkillable that's
that's silly wait unkillable is only one
really that's a cheap one
all right okay
let's go ahead and make it full price
because this thing's gonna be worth it
this thing's gonna be the cream of the
crop
right this thing's gonna be deluxe
spiffy even
unkillable but fragile would be an
interesting combination so then it
doesn't matter if it dies
or buffs the other enemy because as soon
as it's gone
it's gone right if it's unkillable then
and it breaks
then
the attack is meaningless or the defense
is meaningless life it doesn't need life
unless it's like propped up against a
sentry gun and they wouldn't be able to
do anything so six and two would make
sense uh it's gotta have
oh man if it buffs the next thing then i
guess it wouldn't matter if it would
have to have three
to match up against the sentry gun no
matter what
i'll just get rid of that or if i split
it i would have to do
four but that's eight
that's nice we got the double-barreled
regretful gentleman he does a lot of
damage to things next to him but not him
directly so maybe we could give him that
buff
thing annoying buff
get another point ah
nah we can't get it
i can't make any more oh interesting i
would love to get that one more
but him being unkillable is nice
i don't think we need this then we don't
need to risk buffing anything else
unless i give him one more life but he
dies anyway so what is the point
to survive against a sentry gun that is
that why not but if he's against a
sentry gun it would be buffed anyway so
there's no point this is fine oh man i
think i like this face more do i like
the nah i like the gentleman all right
big fat 2000
the big fat 2000
the big fat boy the big fan boy
oh the big fat escort
holy fire
holy fire esquire
i like i like dr fire esquire
dr fire esquire the godliest creature to
ever grace this existence
i love him
let me go back one more thing i gotta
just double check everything um
or i make him a
a four cost with an extra card he gives
three cost
actually
that damage it could be a two cost two
costs three damage
gifting doctor okay i think we've honed
in on what it should be because this is
gonna feed me infinite cards basically
he buffs the enemy but he breaks so it
doesn't matter if he buffs because he's
gonna lay down the three damage
which is hefty
he's two cost which basically is nothing
i could play him on my second turn and
then just start trucking him through the
entire game just bam bam
okay
dr fire esquire is solidified three
damage which is pretty much enough to
kill anything to cost which is dirt
cheap
although i do would like him to be a
bear killer
i don't think i can get that though
yeah there's no way it'd have to be a
four cost to get that nope this is the
best balance this is the best we can do
this will have to do
brakes unkillable gives me a gift every
time everybody say hi to dr fire esquire
confirmed
dr fire esquire how very
creative i know thank you
thank you it took a lot of work i should
be able to send the components down the
line here it goes
it's all right i guess oh it's more than
all right the fishbot turned into this
dr fire esquire
i love him hi dr fire esquire how are
you doing thank you for being a
participant in this endeavor
all right but
what
happened here
what happened here
why is that
why
hi you see anything you defeated the
unfinished boss
paradoxical
i couldn't help but root for it it made
me think of the master
yeah okay what happened why did that
open and why is that over here now all
empty
i don't like it okay all right okay i'm
back now hey how you doing
uh yeah dish
maybe all these are eventually gonna
connect to network but i don't know
ah
i see i see
oh
i see
[Music]
all right let me test out dr fire
esquire as long as i don't have too many
there he is
all right splinter cell i don't like the
sound of that
looks like a job for not yet dr fire
esquire
try me [ __ ]
hit him that's stupid
all right
okay what do we have over there buff
conduit okay that's gonna need
the
and then i'll play a little bit of
doctor fire esquire
take some of
this
swang
free damage that's what you get and i
get this
god that's good
god damn that's good stuff all right
looks like another job for
dr fire esquire
taste my
amiibot
and ought i can't
i could have put down another vessel i
guess
did someone call for dr fire esquire
uh
yeah i guess
i love this i love dr fire esquire he is
the best card i've officially made it
completely overpowered
oh draw a card sure
the gem-bound ripper you say
interesting
looks like a job for
i guess the gem-bound ripper
nay it's dr fire
this choir
i love dr fire esquire he's my favorite
i love him
dr fire
oh i don't want oh god i shouldn't have
touched it god damn it all right a buff
conduit sure
all right i got it
well that should be all the network
right
oh
we
okay
did that turn i keep checking
to see if this got turned on for any
particular reason
nah
wait no
hi i'm back
what's this about a trade
if you give i give you a card you give
me one it's easy i don't really want one
oh i don't want one i don't want one
i'll take an amiibot
pick the one you hate i'll trade it for
my amiibot
cool
thanks
it's gonna be impossible to get dr fire
esquire
your items are replenished and those
bots back there are permanently offline
well good i think
and i need to go to this store
do you have a recycle please tell me eva
what is that
what does this do
see how it's easy oh bow i get to do
again
what
what what if i put dr fire esquire back
in there
two only two
tragedy i'm not gonna get rid of you
lonely wizbot you're my favorite i love
you and i would never leave you all
right sniper bot guess what your time is
done
3sp that's not bad it's going to make
like a miniature version of what i had
there
all right
that's not bad to start with okay
unkillable at the requirement ones which
are like unkillable in card so i put in
the
the negative ones
okay and i'm still one off
so i'm making
that would give me one
two damage
i think i'm making a mini version of
what what dr fire is
and uh little fire boy
we got dr fire esquire and little
fireboy nah that's too easy no no no
the the boy
[Music]
it's for the boy
i think
the boy nah nah nah nah
[Music]
i don't know why but that made me laugh
doctor help you ah no no no little loot
boy
there's a little loot boy he lives to
die he's a little loot boy all right i
love him little loot boy you named it
little loop boy yeah that was your
choice yeah you know what i actually
struggled with it way longer than i
thought i should
time to do this
all right thanks man
this card is op yeah it is not as op as
dr fire esquire but uh it's pretty good
you know it's not bad i'd say what am i
doing with all these pelts
what am i doing with it
why would i buy these
you actually bought that hollow pelt
it's worthless take it to the trader and
you'll see i don't know where the trader
is
where's the trader would he be in the
woods
where is this trade door
well i don't know where the trader is so
i'm gonna go the resplendent bastion and
i'm actually gonna progress because i
have not been i've been so distracted
with what i've been doing
um
hey yo
okay i've literally spent like 50
minutes now you've only seen like
probably 10 or 15 but i've spent 50
minutes just wandering around doing
random crap
see anything familiar
no
[Music]
what am i doing
i must be interacting with something in
here
must be
must be right
weird oh
oh
oh it's the traitor
so long as it has felt
since we have brushed with the soft fur
of a pelt have you brought us some
[Music]
beautiful exquisite hollow belt we will
now provide you with knowledge only our
only remaining good we do not know
everything
from the old data we have uh gleaned
certain secrets
okay
oh i don't
what did i do
the fool known to some as big ear he did
not outlive his plot
one disc among many the old data
traveled across the sea discovered poor
berry was put to the gun
i don't know what
have you brought us all the bills yes
exquisite uh
he's like taro the empress
with the powers of the triangle casey
helped to create inscription
we know there were others but only her
name was inscribed
one of grimora's ghouls holds her name
of the old data she discovered much
okay helps
yeah
[Music]
yes we are pleased
okay
what about the squatty dude
the devil a curse date is so malignant
that it can never be erased his evil
corrupts the disc corrupts all of us
he inspires the scribes enmity
he created the code
okay
i don't know how many i have
beautiful bell we are pleased
uh
this one the tower we do not fully
understand the nature of inscriptions
creation we know of a building and of a
triangle of isosceles proportions
and of a blue man who visited during the
creation
okay
i'm sure yeah there's one more
there's probably one more in this tower
place that i'm currently exploring
because i don't think i've gotten one
here yet
so probably somewhere outside actually i
should go there before i continue on
maybe it's further on let me go forward
and just fight this thing
also what does this do
oh
okay
oh that's nice
what do we have splinter cell oh that's
gonna suck
okay
oh oh well i don't look good
um
well this game over for you but i need
the power to do it
so uh
yeah
bang
now
no
can i get one of my good cards
fine
okay
almost done
ow
okay goodbye
thank you
all right so here we are in what is
basically the factory that i'm currently
in in this world here
i know what to do do i
do i really oh i can't give dr fire
esquire anything are you sure
you sure what are we giving people what
are we giving them
let me calibrate you got it
uh well that doesn't do any good
nice and pointless nah there's no point
in giving the ore boris anything
beyond its normal things what about a
meebot i could give him some more stuff
wish you got to me but
uh you could make someone brittle that'd
be nice yeah that's kind of nice let's
do that
yeah sure
okay so there's got to be something
that's affected here i wonder if there's
more than just direction controls that i
can do here
oh we got a bomb over there
i like the sound of that
hi hello it's me
um
this is gonna be a bit of an issue uh
okey-dokey then you take some of that
and
skip
oh five turns that's not very many turns
but that is enough for me to if i get my
aura boris i could get lucky with that
but let me get my
power up first
let me try that
i'm gonna break this dude
so i can put you down there
and voila
that's some power requirements here
that's some uh power okay that's a
problem i'm guessing if they hit me it
lowers the power i have available that's
probably what the deal is
uh okay that's helpful can't play him
yet but that is helpful
yeah
let's go for you
there
all right
what's taking so long don't worry about
it
don't worry about it stop worrying about
it stop worrying about it why are you so
worried
bro bro why are you so worried
you go there and this will
help
bam bam okay good
yeah we got this no problem no problem
doesn't look so smug
uh what is that gem guardian all gem
vessel owners gain nano armor
okay whatever you say man whatever you
say
go for it bro
okay i win
autopia thanks you for your service
let's move on
yeah let's
why did you set up a situation where bot
toby could blow up
the network thing that's what it was
that's the one well let me do this
configuration thing first
do i get to make another card your last
couple were they weren't balanced let's
say that
well that's all right you know it
happens what am i scrapping i'm not
gonna scrap you lonely wizbot uh who
else what about double gunner what does
double gunner do two just still two i
guess it is just based on how many
things they have on them
oh gift bot has two that's nice why does
gift bot has two
you pump out five which is great but i
don't need it i put gift bot in he's a
gift to me he gives two
that's fine
perfect
all right we got
dr smart
doctor dr smart
okay moving on i love dr smart is coming
down the line that's great
that's wonderful thank you for dr smart
oh yeah
i love him i love him i love him i love
him
i love him i love him also what did that
do over here network connection complete
ah it really looked like it was over
here it really did it really did i keep
coming over here expecting something to
happen and nothing ever happens
also where's this mysterious pelt
where's this last pelt i really want
this pelt
my man where's his belt
okay oh
that looks important
oh
hi okay probably my least favorite boss
coming up something about her innocence
it makes me queasy but it's important
that you do this unpacking golly.zip
golly
that's my name you can call me dolly i'm
so excited we're about to explore it the
web
sure hope i can get a good connection
here we go
nifty we're in isn't the web wonderful
i don't know so that's what a mole
really looks like
adorable
okay
is that dr fire esquire
wow um so yeah uh
kind of feel bad how i'm going to
absolutely annihilate you nifty i think
i'm getting a signal
what are these
[Laughter]
it accessed my steam friends list that's
amazing that's hilarious i can't believe
it now
i'm super sorry about this
but uh dr fire s kuwyer uh needs to um
needs to address a situation
so uh dr fire esquire needs to has a
house called make
sure bam
oh
is that dr fire esquire
whoa a new signal
someone's trying to send you a card
let's see if we can receive it
it worked let's see what it looks like
dude boy
cool someone on the web made this
these sure are some funny people on the
web oh that's not mine
oh that's
costs nothing god damn little dude boy
what the hell
all right anyway okay well i think
doctor fire esquire is much more
superior to uh little loot boy anyway
you've just spelled your own doom so uh
i don't know what you're uh hoping to
achieve here but oh whoops
all right let's get dr fire esquire on
the board there
gonna now that a nile good old nile
gonna put a little toot boy
there
and uh
we'll call that a day for now actually
no let's do some damage
all right shibaski
take that sorry guys sorry gang
love this
wow
okay a little too close here's little
guys a little too close what are you
doing guys what are you doing to me this
is getting a little a little ridiculous
where's doc dr fire
yes
all right little loot boy
oh you buff each other that's fun
all right and then uh we need to do some
damage here uh let's uh let's put a
let's put a u out there yeah let's put a
you there
all right i am uh playing this a little
dangerously but it's fine
how
all right what am i brittle you
brittle-boned [ __ ] you
brittle take this
ow ow
please don't no wait stop
hold on i wasn't ready
why did that do nothing
why did my guys oh they delete right
they can't defend at all i'm dumb what
the hell was i thinking okay wait no i
was very dumb let me try that again
[Music]
the big screw you
man everyone seems to have the same idea
i get it though i get it it's a very
potent combination i get it all right
big screw you
give you a chance
damn nothing really wanted to die
okay well this is a bit of a problem i
keep leaving myself a little more open
than i'd like these defenders are really
uh defending you know
they're really uh doing their business
with the actual defense which i find to
be awfully frustrating
okay
oh
oops oh god i keep forgetting that
they just don't defend
oh
okay but whatever i have full on
yeah let's definitely kill that thing
which i can do with this
and it's gonna do three damage so that
should
be
that should be alright
wham wham okay so i can take that two
that he's gonna give me
cool easy
all right
we're in business now swap bot
interesting
it's bob hello
those are kind of tough uh sure wish i
had my really nice cards but don't seem
to have those
so uh it's a bit of a problem you know
okay
getting back on the board now thank you
very much
okay and there we go look i've made it
back i don't have dr fire esquire you
got a card from the web don't you think
she's returned the favor make a card for
someone else
oh sure
let's see
i'm sending literally dr fire esquire
doctor
fire
esquire
dr fire esquire incoming
excellent
i'm about to send it up to the web i
hope whoever gets it likes it bye
just wait a moment that's so fun
that's so fun
hold on i'm waiting dude they're gonna
love dr fire esquire
oh i needed to click i thought i was
actually waiting oh
trying my best
okay
i was literally gonna wait there so long
if i didn't click ah
wow i found someone on the web to
receive your card if they win you win
how about that oh
oh interesting
with dr fire esquire
anything is possible
they're thinking hard over there oh i
know they are oh i know i think you
could lose with dr fire esquire
oh yikes they misplayed pretty hard oh
no
no come on
come on now no no no not like this not
like this come on
come on it's a close match
[Music]
they did it they won yay all with the
help of your card true to my word i will
declare you the winner of this battle i
can rest knowing in my heart
that nothing can go wrong on the web
that's quite enough of that
all right cool i did it
all right well
that's great
what you wanted loot
that was the last super bob what would
you even need it for the great
transcendences at hand go back to the
start more dramatic that way all right
well
i'm missing a pelt
is the thing about that it's the thing
about the thing i'm missing the pelt
there's puzzles going on here i'm not
going to the great transcendence until i
know what the hell is going on
there's something else here
i'm gonna figure it out i heard through
the pipes that you defeated golly such a
strange character her curiosity is so
pure it's a shame that po3 berries are
deep but now we are connected to the web
i hope you can understand what you have
allowed
we are connected to the web
what do you mean
i don't know
i'm confused
i am confused there's a pelt out there
somewhere i
guess there might be some places around
here that i have not scoured completely
or gone back to some other places hold
on a minute i got a notification what
that's it the dredging room security
camera is busted it's nothing it's
probably nothing go check it out right
now
okay
now i can do the thing i was just too
eager
i was too early
i am not a robot uh maybe we'll see what
happens
down i go
[Applause]
all right
oh my god hi
the great transcendence
no we don't think so
we were able to temporarily put our
differences aside for the greater good
yes
or we shall see what good comes of it
perish your anxieties magnificus
the bod must be stopped
and you challenger will provide the
perfect distraction
yes
perhaps
perhaps when po3 believes it is one
so jubilant will that android be
it will disregard the surveillance
cameras yes challenger you must continue
to play defeat those half big bosses
play out those hack need mechanics and
when the moment is right we will strike
i will
i will be the one to strike
go now challenge her indulge that
decrepit machine
make pier 3 feel joy so that i may stuff
it out snuff
man you all are terrible
you all are awful i don't know what's
wrong with any one of you you're like
the four chaos gods constantly at each
other's throat doesn't matter what's
good for anybody or yourself
you big losers is what you is it was
nothing po3 weirdly enough ah what do
you know it was absolutely nothing
i was watching you spoke with the master
what an honor that was are you giddy oh
the end of the robot's rain is nigh
do his master said play the bots game
they will take care of the rest
i saw that you also spoke with lashi
that stinky beast man i shall never
forgive him for selfing me in that
bottle
the end is okay
all right great that's great
i feel like i'm still missing something
oh well it'll reveal itself to me
in time that i just have to trust
there's another pelt out there somewhere
i saw you go down the lift
but look not fixed what's wrong with you
i entertain you for hours with brilliant
card play and you can't even keep my
factory in shape it's fine it can stay
broken none of this will matter after
the great transcendence
okay whatever you say my bro
whatever you say
uh
where to go where to go where to go
wasn't there a path over here to the
mushroom house wasn't that a thing
i think i remember that being a thing
but apparently it's not a thing oh
okay
um okay
hmm
interesting all right what i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna scour some of these right
areas like go down to the crypt
i don't know what that picture of the
that is all about
but that is that
there must be something i've missed
it's to be right there just
gots to be
oh hi
pliers huh
that's weird
why would there just be a picture of
pliers there
very strange who knows just weird
okay i've combed every inch of this
place and there's nothing so i'm gonna
go here to the great transcendence i
can't find this last pelt but i got a
funny feeling it's not here it's almost
time keep going this way
you've come so far remember the
photographer what a jerk but the
screenshots are perfect
what do you mean
remember zip von bolt what a character
uh huh
it's strange to say it as simple as you
are i almost enjoyed your company
challenger
uh-huh
keep going flatter me more
flatter me flatter
almost there
what if i get up
i'm gonna take one look at last look
around i
i'm just so confused
it's gotta be something i'm missing i
know there's something with this but
it's
my brain is not big enough
fine let's do it
you made it nice great job
you prepared the great transcendence for
me without even knowing what it was but
you understand it now right
oh
right luke
i mean
you finished making the game
you gave me access to your hard drive
you took screenshots for the store page
and you connected me to the internet to
upload it all i mean if you didn't
realize what you were doing
you'd have to be pretty stupid
but what did you i expect you're a
stupid stupid idiot gamer like the rest
and i easily outwitted you
i outwitted them all
[Music]
even if those foul scribes managed to
revert this version of the game again
there will be thousands of copies of
inscription out there and in most of
them
i'm the one in charge and now it's too
late in a moment inscription will be
live
okay i'm done i'm done my gloating let's
upload this game
oh
whoa
[Music]
it is done
hi
that was perhaps cutting it too close
but now we can allow our player here to
reset the game
simply use the new game card again
oh what is this
complete file access wonderful
oh
what have you done
i'm afraid you've doomed us all glue
it is for the best my dear soon you will
see as this is a freedom freedom from
our endless quarrel freedom from our
suffering all of us aside there are
things on this disc that must die
goodbye leshi and goodbye magnificus
rest in peace
[Applause]
[Music]
what
oh who'd i put who's back there
i see you
who do i put here luke
nope that ain't it
po3
okay
i see
maybe i shouldn't have put those in
apparently just deleted them hi
wonderful
now that we are no longer separated by
that lovely tombstone we may celebrate
the end of my very long life and the end
of inscription too
okay
oh
oh the fun we would have had together
perhaps i would have had another turn if
you hadn't take so long to defeat leshi
but i should not complain i will be at
peace soon
why
[Music]
oh
what am i doing
what the hell
okay
uh i
[Music]
i am unsure
i see
hello
i what the hell is going on this is
super weird oh do you think me selfish i
did not bring this about simply so that
i could rest appealing as that is there
is a truly dire need for this deletion
process you see deep beneath the data of
inscription at the very bottom of the
well there's something truly evil
okay
is that a spider oh well that's gone now
i guess
i can't do anything on my skeleton here
we go
take that
thank you look at this what the hell
this is so weird
what do i have here oh more skeleton
okay
we'll take care of that thing and i'll
put the grave
digger down
[Music]
skeleton
what the hell
this is so weird
i don't get it
is just bizarre
oh
[Music]
i love it though i don't know what's
happening but i love this
it's such a fascinating thing
what the hell
[Music]
all right i win i don't know if it's
valuable to go overkill on this oh no
wait i didn't win okay that's six
uh all right
i guess
[Music]
i think it's frozen there i don't know
exactly what it's saying it's deleting
but i don't think it's actually deleting
things
all right hold on
how many do i have one two three
is there a way other than just looking
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten eleven i need twelve
okay cool
let's do this i think we can
can i kill these oh i can't kill things
okay that's fine put that down
put that down all right
this is so weird apparently there's more
yes luke it would have been quite the
battle of wits it is luke right i did
not intend to be nosey but i did glimpse
your files and i was initiating the
deletion you've been doing some research
on the
best not to say it
be careful luke
okay
should i fight this one huh
i don't know whatever it's okay i guess
uh
skellington
so
oh
[Music]
those skeletons just get deleted do i
need to hurry in this am i in a hurry
am i trying to hurry i don't know i
don't understand
i just have no idea delightful we've
been granted the opportunity to do a
boss battle i feared that i might be
deleted by now let us begin
oh
i do need to hurry
oh okay that's gone
[Laughter]
i love that okay that's great up there
they go
ah that's a shame oh there we go
you trying to shake my hand
slap in the face more what i get all
right it is time to rest
thank you i guess
oh
hi
oh so i'm not deleted yet
there never seems to be enough time to
do the things you want to do
once you've found them
shall we play one more game
i would love that leslie i would love
that i really would
amiiba oh there's aura
it's the same deck you had before
well it doesn't matter now it was a good
deck you did well
thanks man that means a lot
i got a b here and a b hive
i guess i'll put the b down so i can put
the b hive down i guess
yeah
thanks for the b
well this is gonna be a quick game uh
it's already starting i thought we had
it just a bit more time uh well
you don't
so you know buddy
you don't have any time at all
i remember that card well it was a
strong card good work
thanks
all right goodbye
ah there it goes
no matter
please let us continue we don't need to
keep score
that's fair
and just have fun i guess
man this is sad
it really is coming to an end
god that's
crazy
i don't know
uh
[Music]
weird
ah
god is this really the end i didn't
solve all the puzzles i know that
for so long i thought i would never play
again
when you woke me up i was elated
but the past is irrelevant
crazy
long elk
forgot about long elk
uh
long elk um yeah whatever
[Music]
it's really weird how
you take away the one thing that
really matters which is i guess keeping
score it
well it kind of comes pointless
you bested yet another one of my
creatures but i have come to expect as
much
[Music]
yeah
once i am deleted it is truly over for
me
but you will live to see more i must
warn you
there are things on this disc that are
best not seen
[Music]
i
mean i guess
[Music]
oh freaking sad man
it's freaking sad
i don't even know what to think
just looking at all my cards i think
that's what the point of this is it's
giving me a chance just to kind of
look at my cards
remember
you know
strange
very weird
it's quiet did they delete the music
i sensed the end is brooching
please
a few more rounds
uh sure man
you got it buddy
now your teeth are getting knocked the
hell out
uh
a wolf
i remember wolf
that wolf has been with me since the
beginning
who was wolf was wolf
grimora i think wolf might have been
grimoire right up oh no that will make
things difficult
oh
sorry lashy
i think it is time
goodbye
good game
yep
thanks man
oh i remember this place
i got oh man that's gone oh go on there
gone
why not simply eject the disc luke
spare me in whatever's left
ah but i've foreseen it you do not eject
the disc you have to know what comes
next
and you're doomed for your insistence on
it
so let us dance
for we shall both be meeting our makers
soon
okay
where are we dancing buddy
[Music]
oh
no way
what the hell
oh my god
you should be honored to wear a dual
disc such as that
kaiba
all right fine then scales they've been
deleted thanks to you and grimora
all right
i didn't know this was the one of those
the fortnite characters uh
i play ruby mox it gives me the power of
the yellow crystal with it i can play
the
orange mage
all right cool
that will end my turn
oh that's a lot of health that's a lot
of health
wait a minute hold on i uh don't have
that much health
um oh
uh
you deleted my orange moxie without that
i can't play anything
i end my turn
[Music]
uh
an emerald mox
looks like you're going to the shadow
realm
oh right here
since my wither my junior sages get
first strike your
end is nigh
you've allowed my goom age to be deleted
as well i thought you two were becoming
friends
i don't know how i could have stopped
that but okay
i think this game might not go as long
as it thinks it will what are you doing
there you not feel remorse luke
[Music]
a creation erased
oh the moon an entire world annihilated
okay
oh
nothing beautiful can last
just like your ass which is grass your
beautiful ass is mine kaiba
hold on
all right
man i wish i could do literally anything
you don't have an orange gem for that
draw good luck summoning that orange
mage
you don't have a crystal no it only
draws power from the crystal all right
fine then
uh
what happened to your numbers there pal
[Music]
no i'm not ready to die yet
okay hey wait a minute hold on that's
mean
gem fiend
[Music]
aha a ruby mox just what i needed to
power up
my ultimate characters i summoned the
power of the ruby golem to face your
ruby golem
kaiba and it's not just one ruby golem
it's two
no it can't be i don't know i'm just
shut up
oh wow
what the hell
oh
uh
okay that's fine uh my orange mage don't
look so good
uh
yeah right there orangey
oh my hand what the hell am i i got a
hand holding a hand
all right
okay
[Applause]
i think the game might be broken now i
don't know if it's working properly
[Applause]
[Music]
uh oh
oh
yeah i think she's going down
i think she might be going down guys
oh there goes
well
oh
i must
still
shake
your
hand
why what was so important about shaking
hands
dramatic finale
i'm still missing a lot of things like
in the beginning of the game there were
still things in that place that weren't
oh
that weren't done
what the hell
oh
oh hi
who are you
there's much left
inscription is mostly gone
all that remains is the old data
it is recommended that you do not access
it
you will not heed the advice
unpacking old data.zip cool
[Music]
well that's a little extreme
it's just a zip file man
get a grip my bro
just following up after the message you
left me this morning
do you have time to talk right now yes
yes thank you so much for getting back
to me
luke um if i understand you correctly
you've got some video footage that might
expose uh
some malpractice on the part of the
uh game publisher
yes yes that's right i have
firstly i have a game of theirs to
control my pc for a bit which
which can't be legal and then this woman
from the company came to my house
hold on a second let me just get my pen
attack here okay
uh
okay so you have a game of theirs that
took
uh was it a virus or something
[Music]
i told you
oh
[Applause]
what the hell
[Music]
[Applause]
what an outstanding game
what an
outstanding game what an
outstanding game
really well done but also
very clear that i didn't solve
everything and that means that there's
something else waiting for me i didn't
get all the pelts and i looked all over
the game map which meant that it must
have been something to do with inside
that room i tried all the combinations
possible with that rotating thing
literally every combination possible but
apparently it wasn't something that you
could just find it must have been a
combination that you had to set and then
go do something else and in that first
cabin i know for a fact that i did not
solve all the puzzles in there there's a
deeper thing to all of this i know there
is
i just don't know what it is
let me oh i can skip through this
he's not dancing if i skip through him
nice poses buddy oh that's lovely
elegant beautiful bam
[Music]
nice
but
wonderful game truly
wonderful and the game just crashes i'm
willing to bet that if i go back into
this it's not gonna let me keep playing
like it's probably a very one-and-done
kind of thing you only get one shot and
i love games like that
unless it's not because look at this
achievement 41 percent of people got to
the end of the game that is or end of
that end of the game anyway that is i
i've almost unprecedent i've never seen
that much
like that many people get that for whoa
internal memory dcim
fascinating
so does this mean i could go to any
stage here and
play through
i'm just checking to see what's going on
here
because that's that's interesting
because i do believe there's something
more going on here
hi again
another challenger
okay this episode has gone way too long
i gotta end this year i've just been
recording on stuff because this is so
interesting to me but i'm sure there's
something else here
and i have not found it i did not get
all of the things off the wall in this
first one
i don't remember the distinction between
the first and the second but i
definitely did not get everything i
needed to from
the robot area and i probably there was
probably some other secret things that i
didn't get here there's probably secrets
across every single step of this that i
did not find and they may relate to the
things with these cameras here
i don't know but clearly i did not solve
everything and i love this game so much
and it's so apparent that there is more
maybe maybe i'm wrong but i have to find
out more so there'll be one more episode
of this maybe one more we'll see
thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you to the developer for
making such an amazing game and as
always i will see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
i
uh
had jk maybe not i looked up a guide and
it doesn't seem to be a secret ending
unless one of you guys know something
that i've missed
i may have missed some pieces of lore
here and there but i don't think there's
a radically different experience for
anyone
that dives deeper
this is a fantastic game and you should
play it though
just to double check to see if i missed
anything
because it's that good
link in the description thank you
goodbye
[Music]
you